hello and good morning uh welcome to
time to act
how lack of knowledge in the cultural
sector creates barriers for disabled
artists and audiences
we are incredibly um
grateful for your time this morning
my name is ben evans and i am one of
your co-hosts today
i am a white man in my mid-40s
i've got short brown hair
a slightly ginger beard and today i'm
wearing a brown suit
i self-define as disabled
and uh so you can't see the
cane that um
that that frequently uh
accompanies me
um
i have a digital background
on which um you can see the logo of our
project europe beyond access
and it also has the logos of the key
partners of the project british council
oriented roger dente dance festival pet
art camp gnargle skarnerstown theater
anastasia stiggy
and holland dance festival the
partnerships of eur europe beyond access
it also has the logo of our thunder
the creative europe program of the
european union to whom we're hugely
grateful
caroline
hello hello everybody um it's a joy to
be with you my name is caroline brodich
and i
am a performance maker choreographer and
also the ceo
of arts access victoria and i am your
other co-host
and today i am coming to you from the
traditional lands of the brinron people
of the koala nations in melbourne
australia
i'm in my home office
i am a white
woman now in my 50s
i have an asymmetric curly haircut and
today i'm wearing a hot pink top with
red framed glasses
thanks caroline
um i just wanted to start with some
housekeeping
normally at the bottom of your screen
you will see the cc button closed
captions
um and that is where you can find
english live captions of the event
um
but
in the chat right now
uh sorry yes in the chat will be pasted
a separate link
where you can see
captions translated into other languages
so that is a link that was sent to you
in your email but also it's being posted
into that
chat right now
the link where those languages can be
found so please choose from all of the
wonderful languages we have japanese
korean
portuguese french spanish it's an
amazing
group of
attendees we're excited to have you here
um
in the
pre-recorded section later on we will be
sharing some pre-recorded material
feel free to use the slider
within the zoom function to make
that smaller if you would like to see
our sign language interpreters british
sign language or international sign
there is no spoken
translation
but
during the session you will see
appearing on the bottom of the the page
a globe which is a translation globe and
this is only for five minutes at the end
of the presentation where a film will be
shown in italian with english subtitles
but if you would like to listen to it in
english you can do so there
but we'll let you know nearer the time
when that comes up
you can see already um that there is a q
and a question and answer function and
that's where we would like you to ask
questions of the research team that we
will introduce in a moment
you can also see a chat function the
chat function is where we would like you
to
communicate if you have any technical
needs or any questions but just to let
you know caroline and i will not be
reading the chat
our
technical team will so if you want to
ask a question as part of the discussion
please use the q and a function
great thanks ben
um so today's event will run for two
hours
um for the first 30 minutes coming up
next we're going to hear from the
research team
at on the move
who are going to give us an overview and
some highlights from the research
we've also invited two professionals
from the cultural sector to join us
in a research dialogue with the research
team
to help us to understand some of the key
findings
of the report
then we'll be hearing from a panel in
which disabled artists arts advocates
and mainstream cultural managers
share their personal response to the
report
and this will be followed by a
conversation with the head of creative
europe
at the european commission
and then there is an opportunity for you
to ask questions of the research team
so we strongly ask and encourage you to
share your questions
uh in the q a function throughout the
session today's session
and will finally end as ben
suggested with a provocation
uh a film from the italian disabled
artist association aldequa
so please send your questions as they
come up to the um through the q a
function
thanks caroline um and so we're going to
make a start i'm going to invite geordie
belter from on the move to
turn this camera on and to join us for
the first session of this meeting um in
which you'll be introducing the time to
act report
um jordy if i can invite you to give a
short description of yourself and
introduce us to the time to act report
sure good morning everyone it's a
pleasure to talk to you i'm i'm talking
from uh to you from barcelona
i'm a white man a dark grayish hair and
glasses and i'm wearing
a purple
turtleneck
sweater today
and i'll be presenting um some of the
main findings of the final report of
time to act which we are presenting
today
um
[Music]
yeah and
johann flock and marilla sood who have
also been part of the research team will
be joining us later for the question and
answer segment of the of the session
um
time to act uh examines uh the
importance of knowledge experience and
solutions as a way to make the
performing arts more accessible and
inclusive of disabled artists and
audiences this has been
a report
a year and a half in the making
which has examined
the knowledge existing
within performing arts organizations in
europe of the work done by disabled
artists and which means of support can
exist to foster the inclusion and
recognition of work by disabled artists
has also examined experiences in working
with disabled artists and hosting
disabled audiences
and finally it has examined
recommendations and solutions to improve
the situations in this area it is based
on mainly three sources of information
and
analysis
firstly an analysis of existing
literature in this field a wide range of
publications
guidance toolkits
policy reports
etc that exist in this field
the results of an online survey that was
answered by professionals of different
kinds in 35 countries
and finally a set of interviews and
conversations and particularly in the
last few months
we've presented the initial findings of
the report to a number of national and
international events and there's been a
very enriching feedback of those
presentations and we've
also developed a new round of interviews
with professionals companies and
organizations to refine
the initial findings of the of the
research
[Music]
one of the main findings of time to act
is
the fact that there is limited knowledge
of work by disabled artists among
performing arts organizations in europe
so over 50 percent of the respondents to
the survey said that they had poor or
very poor knowledge of work done by
disabled artists and only 16
so that's
one in six approximately said that they
had good or excellent knowledge of that
work
when we move to the
experience in supporting and presenting
work by disabled artists one important
finding here
is
that the frequency with which uh
organizations in the performing arts
present work by disabled artists is very
irregular
so uh 15
of uh venues festivals and similar
organizations do not present any work by
disabled artists and another 53 percent
so more than a half
present less than one production per
year
less and only less than six percent
present four or more productions
involving
disabled artists uh every year
what else do we know as regards uh the
work or the presentation of work by
disabled artists one of the
important findings here is that for many
professionals in the sector
it is difficult to find reliable
information sources and this remains the
critical aspect
in
the difficulties in making progress in
this area
when
professionals and organizations in the
field
need to
find trusted
sources of information they mainly recur
to disabled artists and professionals
themselves who become key sources of
information
as well as peer arts organizations and
specialized services
and what we also found is that there is
a very important role played by european
networks and european funded projects
in order to balance out the asymmetries
that exist across countries because
there's a few countries that have a
relatively good level of information and
knowledge in this area but this is very
unevenly spread across
europe so the importance of european
cooperation
is very high
another finding concerns the fact that
uh 31
of arts organizations that we surveyed
say that they do not look for new work
by disabled artists
and
we also found that almost
almost half of the organizations say
that they are not confident that their
programs are accessible for disabled
artists and that remains a gap to be
addressed
the situation is a bit better when it
comes to accessibility for disabled
audiences but here there's also
aspects to address
in general
measures
enabling the accessibility of disabled
audiences are adopted more frequently
than in the case of disabled artists so
a majority of venues have toilets that
are accessible with a wheelchair and
there's a number of other measures to
enable enable accessibility for
audiences that have been adopted however
there is much progress still needed
particularly in areas like communication
we found that
only 19
of the venues and festivals have an
accessible website and only 13
and 12 have accessible communication
materials and accessible booking
respectively and there's another gap as
regards the training and awareness
raising of staff including
front of house staff in performing arts
venues
one
important finding is also that
a key driver for change a thing that
enables organizations to make progress
is when they have
uh disabled people in their staff or
when they have allocated
responsibilities to someone in their
staff or have an allocated budget for
aspects related to disability and
accessibility
and
another finding of the research is that
in general it seems that often
the perception
of organizations is overconfident as
regards the degree of accessibility they
are enabling
because often the percentage of people
that say they are confident about how
accessible they are is higher than what
the evidence of the measures adopted
then shows
the research was conducted in the
context of the covet 19 pandemic and
that was one of the issues that we also
examined and
there was a sense that the pandemic has
brought about new risks and threats
firstly because of the fact that
people with disabilities
feel particularly vulnerable and that
threatens the continued participation as
audiences in performing arts events
secondly because
initial evidence shows that in a context
in which unemployment and economic
difficulties in many cultural sectors
has increased
a particular situation affects disabled
artists that might be uh
feeling a particularly strong impact in
terms of their employ employability and
employment opportunities and finally
there is also a sense that in a context
in which uh there are many needs and
policy priorities the needs and
attention to people with disabilities
might be particularly neglected and the
the any progress that had been made uh
may uh be left behind and there's a
there's a risk of going back in some of
the progress
uh made
the final uh section of the report
focuses on solutions and recommendations
and how progress can be made and and to
summarize
a much longer discussion there's three
main elements that uh come up one is the
importance of putting in place cultural
policies policies that focus on
accessibility and which look after the
needs of people with disabilities
and that's based on the evidence that
there's some countries where progress
has been made and that generally where
there have been ambitious policies and
measures in this area secondly the
importance of engaging with
gatekeepers and by that we mean the
important role of curators producers and
training institutions and the the
particular
importance of training institutions was
raised in many of the interviews
with it
as uh
gatekeepers and let's say uh asians that
have a very critical role in fostering a
more inclusive and diverse sector and
also the importance of making these
gatekeepers more diverse themselves and
finally the fact that there are a number
of toolkits uh guides and other
practical resources that can
be very useful
tools but often these are not
sufficiently known or they only exist in
some countries and there is a particular
demand from professionals in the sector
to have more available guidance focusing
in particular on how to make artistic
projects more accessible
how
to foster the development of disabled
audiences and finally how to make
workplaces more accessible diverse
and inclusive
and there is an understanding that it is
particularly arts funders and national
ministries of culture that should take
the lead in facilitating progress but as
you can see in this graphic there is
this is very much a shared
responsibility so there is also an
understanding that specialist service
providers local and regional authorities
and national and european professional
networks have a very important role to
play in enabling uh progress
and i think i'll leave it
here just to
remind that the time to act report is
now available on the disability ads
international
website and that we will be happy to
further discuss its findings in the
coming minutes through the q a thank you
thank you so much uh jordy um
for that and i'm sure people have lots
of questions
and as caroline mentioned uh later on we
will be posing the questions that you
put in the q a
box to the research team
um and caroline will be reading these
now and preparing to ask them later on
however to start this process um we have
invited two senior representatives of
the european cultural sector
to ask the research team some questions
so
i'm pleased to invite
johann flock one of the research team uh
really good to see you johan but also if
i could ask now for julian arab
the international advisor at the french
office for contemporary performing arts
circulation honda and joe verrant the
senior producer at the uk organization
unlimited to join us thank you so much
julian i'm going to ask you to turn uh
to ask a couple of your questions first
after briefly describing yourself thank
you yes thank you ben
and hello everyone so i'm julian adam
i'm
a woman in my mid-30s white passing with
asymmetric brown hair
and i'm in my home today because we're
alternating between home and office
and i have a white background around me
i hope that's enough
and um maybe i can go straight into the
questions uh
i am first of all thank you for this and
it was such a great read and such an
interesting report to go through and
maybe one of the key elements is that it
really shifts the responsibility of
overcoming the obstacles faced by
disabled artists and individuals to
those who are in positions of power and
i'm also speaking from uh organizational
position myself
so
and and usually and too often this
responsibility is put on the shoulders
of the artists and professionals
themselves
so
now that we have identified this lack of
knowledge and it is clearly named
i'm wondering what is your sense
of the willingness of organizations to
learn
um and i would maybe connect this
directly to another
to something that is mentioned in the
report which is overconfidence of having
the impression of already doing enough
and then connecting it to another
complex
observation which is very often
organizations with all the good
intentions uh think that they are doing
the right thing when
the approach and in practice it actually
goes against
what uh activists or advocacy or
disabled advocacy groups are pushing for
so here i'm wondering like what is your
sense of
the ability or willingness or humility
of organizations to go through the
process of learning and unlearning some
of the ways that are
in place
thanks julia and johan over to you
yeah thank you for this question a very
interesting question just to briefly
describe myself i'm
a white man in its uh mid-forties um i
have dark hair and a
short
beard and i'm wearing a black
tilt and neck sweater today i'm sitting
in a very typical
attic flat in paris um
you are
putting the finger on something very
important and interesting i would say
that
everybody have so far in the you know in
the surveys in the interviews and all
the discussions we had
have a strong willingness to do more uh
people don't usually think they are
doing enough and many respondents were
humbly admitting not being knowledgeable
enough during the entire research
process and proposing to connect us with
specialized organization because they
were saying i don't know enough but it
is very interesting what you're doing so
this lack of knowledge means also the
lack of what uh uh
gatekeepers uh uh curators artistic
leaders know and don't know
and obviously they don't master
generally a lot of the you know the
variety of disabilities and and what we
observe is what comes first in mind of
most people is the physical disability
as we all know
um
so the the the interviews and public
discussions often was
a moment of
raising awareness you know a key point
to actually
discuss about disability issues and many
realize there were not actually quite
aware of what they could be doing
and what we observe also is there is a
intersectionality or transversality and
many professionals are overwhelmed with
priorities
we we're living in in in a very
particular time in our society where
there are a lot of urgent issues for for
them to deal with
um but in terms of um
how to to to say that in terms of uh
um
unlearning uh i think this is a very uh
interesting term that you are using we
always
um
see that the best advice in this
unlearning process
is to involve disabled people themselves
and for them to lead the change
and this is what we call the nothing
about us without us
principle
in in many venues and festivals mostly
from the independent scene in the
western northern europe but also in
south europe
more developments are observed when
in-house personnel or personnel with a
lived experience
are in charge of leading the change in
the organizations
it feels that the gatekeepers have a
very important role to play in this but
to give you
the scope or an idea of this massive
cultural change that we need to operate
many non-disabled artists also are not
always willing to adapt their work for
disabled audiences for example
so we see that this unlearning process
not only goes towards you know the
gatekeepers the curators the people in
charge or in power in venice and
festivals but really have to reach out
everybody in our ecosystem
thanks johan and i think that answer
that you've given actually links with a
question that joe i know you were very
interested in so i wonder if i could
hand over to you to
to follow that out
well i mean i'm very interested it was
fascinating to read it but deeply
shocking um
sorry my name is joe behrendt uh i'm
senior producer for unlimited in the uk
i'm a 50-plus which means i am senior in
the older sense of the word being around
the block um i've got purple hair i'm in
bed at the moment not having a good
health day and i'm wearing a t-shirt
that says vulnerable
uh still valuable
um i've got a question that
is about programming really just in
terms of the volume
of work that uh
that people are putting out because
people said whether they were
programming or not i just wonder whether
you've got a sense of
who is programming what at what level
it's like i'll be seeing
small companies and solo performances or
is it extending
into main stage work and i'm really
curious about what you would have liked
to have found we always say in the uk
that if disabled people make up 22
percent of our population
where and what figure should that result
uh in programming we certainly aren't 22
of what's programmed here
yes i'm really curious about your
thoughts
yeah it's a it's an interesting question
also because um
if i i go
immediately to the facts and figures or
the percentages
we see
it is a very uh difficult approach to to
to to adopt percentages
or let's say quotas as a solution that
was often mentioned by by uh the
interviewees we
we had because sometimes it looks like a
very deep contextualized approach in
many contexts the number of disabled
artists is very low as you know and
sometimes there are no
professional disabled artist and in
interviews many many people pointed out
the necessity to make arts education and
training more accessible
including all the long life learning
education master class seminars etc
of course arts education was not part of
the focus of this research but it came
so often in conversation um also to
complain about about the
the low number of uh disability led arts
projects in
most european countries
um so we have also here a lot of gaps
between you know
the different european context just to
give you an example that
we would put in our final report uh in
an interview with uh
the fiat
theater academy in poland um the the
lead uh drama teacher was saying that in
all his career
uh every time they uh you know open
applications they receive a thousand
applicants uh
for only 20 seats and during his entire
career he never saw a young disabled
person applying to the drama school
which means that there is also uh in
this cultural change that we were
talking about there is also a lot of um
of work to be done to not only make
these institutions and art education
program accessible
but also there is a perception or
prejudice that we need to work on in
terms of
what kind of career a disabled young
person can embrace
um
and there are a million reasons why
probably they don't in terms of lack of
exposure to artistic work
the ability to actually make a living
and the risk of losing sometimes
governmental allowance was
put you know on the table quite often
um so in terms of uh
challenges
we have a lot to do also in terms of
redefining what is artistic virtuosity
versatility etc
but in terms of the all the names that
came
we see a lot of of the usual suspects i
would say uh in the artistic company
many of them based in the uk that are
able to identify
identified invisible
and there we see also that some
british-based companies were very
successful in being able to
you know build relationship with many
european venues and festivals
so yeah
i think that's a really good point to
bring in julian who had a question
specifically about
geography and geographic imbalance yeah
i i had exactly this question that
relates to context and just to give a
little bit of background as to where it
comes from we are at honda at the
together with a number of partners at
the end of the reshape project which is
a european project a research and
development project that
questions
and tries to propose solutions
for several challenges within the
cultural sector um
and this question of context
whenever we are
talking about
overall european recommendations comes
back onto
onto play and it becomes really
important to find ways of formulating
recommendations that don't stem from
only one geography or only one
context and the report actually
acknowledges the challenges that you as
researchers faced with regard to
geographic diversity and interlocutors
and also sizes of organizations
so i'm wondering how this aspect is
taken into consideration
previously like throughout during the
the research but also in the future
phases
yeah you're right i mean there is the
idea that the um
there's a lot of gaps like georgie was
reminding us in existing literature
guidance documentation access to
information etc
during this research process we took all
the recommendations from the field and
the solution that are already uh
suggested in many contexts and
reinforced them
by
giving feedback on on the
um
on on these solutions proposed and to
have them dialogue with the data that we
collected of course it is a european uh
study so the purpose is to to tap into
this uh european relevance the european
competencies uh uh and to
address the responsibilities
from the field itself but for example at
european level it could be interesting
to have eu institutions facilitating
exchange of good practices
and fostering
peer learning because
there are many guides and examples of
progress that could be inspiring
which can then be adapted to local
context
in the feedback and interviews we always
try to counterbalance the gaps in terms
of geographical coverage and we could
you know reach out to many uh
professionals in romania serbia poland
et cetera et cetera
and we tried also to to reach out to
organizations from the so-called
independent field but also a more
institutional field you know the state
theaters and state companies uh also to
highlight some of the the elements that
we were talking about in terms of
education
visibility how do you hire talents etc
so instead of
being inspired by one model
we were trying to propose processes
that can be adopted or contextualized
beyond a right-based approach that is
always very valuable and that has
potentially a lot of positive impacts
in all countries
thank you for that question and that
answer um i think we've got time to
squeeze in one
uh
one more
short question from joe and a short
answer from you johan if possible well
i'd love to ask about the reasons for
inaction particularly what you picked up
around a lack of funding i'm really
interested because we often hear a lack
of funding being an issue is it a lack
of funding or i often wonder whether
it's people not prioritizing funding
that they already have we're talking
about art in the art sector many
organizations have artistic budgets
might it just be about spreading their
budget so that it includes disabled
artists do you think from the people
that you spoke that the only solution is
more money or are the more inventive
ways to look at finance
i mean it's um it's very it's a very
good question uh because money comes
very often in the conversation and as
you you saw in the report uh venues and
festivals are are considering the lack
of funding as a real obstacle to do more
both uh towards engaging more with the
artists and engaging more with disabled
audiences
so when it comes to supporting disabled
artists there is an awareness that
production and distribution means have
to be increased to cover specific
measures
that go from mobility to longer
production processes extra assistance
and sometimes also very practical
physical access to the workspace that
doesn't always exist
and this idea of challenging the way
the normative way of producing stage
work
implies
extra extra cost and for disabled
audiences i have to say that we observed
in many many countries that the uh
accessible marketing material accessible
booking system easy reading accessible
website etc
employing extra team or training
existing team members in communication
marketing have have a cost
one of the costs that
is
is very often mentioned just to give you
an example
is
the investment needed for the sign
language translation
and the workload behind the scenes to
make it happen
so
money is an issue um but um
of course uh are you right in pointing
out that it is an easy you know a trick
sometimes used to say
we can't do it because we don't have the
money
i would say that
some of these tax accessible
measures could be adopted by
organization at their own initiative
and indeed they are good practices in
this
respect the report also stresses that
governments across
have different approaches as regards
disability and
there were more ambitious and inclusive
policies
the the more the uh
the more the policies are ambitious
the more funding is available uh to put
it this way
so ideally it's a combination of the two
a combination of arts organization being
proactive
and deciding it is a priority but also
the policy and funding systems
supporting the progress
oh this is where i feel we need a good
hour on this especially because i would
have to share a personal experience of
hearing uh
one of the intendants at a major german
theater explain that he would only
consider
extra access if given more money and i
did think you are one of the most
well-funded organizations in the world
and you're just choosing not to make
this work accessible it's a choice it's
an active choice but maybe i've just
slipped out of moderator role and into
giving opinion that's my that's my
prerogative
i'm going to say thank you to all of you
um johan we'll be meeting you again
uh later on with a q a with others and i
want to thank julian and joe and you can
disappear now a little housekeeping
update um a reminder that please post
questions in the q a box not in the chat
our technical team will respond to chat
but we caroline and i will look at the q
a
and also you will find i'll ask my
colleague now to repost the stream text
link if you would like translated
captions i know some people arrived a
little late and maybe didn't hear that
announcement
and so you can find that in in the chat
now
thanks caroline
thanks ben
um and i'm with you on you could we
could spend a day having these
conversations
um earlier in the week i recorded a
conversation with a number of disabled
and non-disabled artists and arts
professionals
these included philip pavlak artist
producer activist from poland
sonia palmatea
artist
teacher and activist from the
netherlands
maria vlacio
ceo of
assesso cultura portugal
tanya
mangalanigam
is the project manager of dialogue
program at schooner's dance theatre in
sweden
and claudio gaitani from who's an actor
filmmaker and founder member of aldequa
artists
in italy and also the director of the
film that we'll see at the end of today
i asked each of the panelists to share
with me their reflections on the report
what surprised them
what it confirmed for them and finally
what they would want others to take from
it
here is a 30-minute excerpt from our
conversation
so sonia could you please give us your
response um to the report and describe
yourself for us
um
first of all i'm a white female 53 years
old
with long brownish hair and nowadays
some gray coming through i have to say
today i'm wearing a blue greenish jumper
and purple glasses
um thank you caroline and and thank you
for
allowing me to be part of the
presentation of a report
i think was and still is very needed in
trying to build evidence
and give
arguments why it's really time to act
nothing about us without us that's the
motto from the un convention and i was
really happy to read in the report
um
in the solutions part that it is an
important way towards
more inclusion
and it says in the report and i quote
the involvement of this disabled people
is therefore absolutely necessary to
create interesting offers to disabled
people that they can trust
um
after reading the report i asked the
team about the number of responses from
the netherlands
and there are only seven
to be honest i was not really surprised
but i was very disappointed
and it made me think if this is
reflecting the lack of knowledge or lack
of interest or maybe a completely
different reason
unfortunately
there's another fact
which is really not helping in the
overall feeling about inclusion in the
netherlands
it's the fact that like in most
countries of europe like uk germany
portugal the u.n convention was signed
in 2007
and ratified in 2008 or 2009.
in the netherlands it took till 2016
till it was ratified and even until now
the optional protocol isn't ratified
and this optional protocol enables an
individual to get their rights at the
u.n committee in geneve when you're not
able to get it under your national law
so
so much for equal rights
the other thing that resonated with me
in the report
was the part about the overconfidence
and i quote again
therefore maybe some overconfidence not
backed by evidence on the actual
improvements in accessibility for both
artists and audiences
and again when i look in the netherlands
then i have to say yes where there are
some more inclusive inclusive
performances on stage yes there is more
intention
paid to disabled art and an agenda and a
code have been written
but something on paper doesn't mean that
it's done or actually working
and yes there are some wonderful
individual initiatives
however
this will not bring about enough
structural changes as long as we don't
support artists in their education and
in giving them perspective basically
giving them the tools and the
opportunities to develop but also allow
them time
and not too quickly play the quality
card and use that as an excuse to not
program dutch disabled artists
the other day i made a comparison to the
paralympic games and the paralympic
games that
were a worldwide podium has been helping
disabled people to develop in their
sports and giving them some real
perspective and challenges
it does raise the question for me why
can't we do that for the arts
and from an audience point of view for
example in the uk and in germany the
paralympic games were shown on
television
more than several hours a day
in the netherlands we had exactly
five minutes after the main news and 30
minutes at 10 o'clock in the evening
although the level of performance was
very high
um i have to say as duchess we are very
good in talking and meetings
but unfortunately disabled people are
not asked to the table very often
and i do experience that myself and i
find
way too often i get a phone call after
things went wrong or asking me how to
solve a problem instead of getting in
touch with me up front or with somebody
else that doesn't necessarily have to be
me of course
but believe me that saves a lot of
stress time
and money
the whole pandemic situation has not
made it any easier i have to say and i'm
scared it will only have made it worse
on the other hand there are also good
things for example being able today to
attend this meeting
and launch in a digital way and i really
hope that we're not going to lose that
because
i hope that this report and the
disallowed artists and their art and
knowledge are will be taken more serious
because without them i think we're
missing out on a unique and maybe much
required perspective on the world out
there
those were my reflections
thank you sonya
that's uh there's so much food for
thought in that it's brilliant
um i'm going to next invite philip to
share
your reflections on the report phillip
over to you
thank you carol lane
and at the beginning i am a young man
with a bird and
red hair there is a large
window behind my back and i am sitting
in an office
and i'm dressed in the black clothes
with a big
headphones on my head
um
yeah also that reading all the report
was
something really
uh
helpful for me because it's uh
uh collecting all the knowledge
and all the
discussions that we had made in the last
few months or years
about the sector of arts and
disabilities in europe
also we had a lack of
data and
documents that we can you know send to
the decision makers in theaters that i'm
working with
and here we have the big report and
my main job right now is being a theater
producer in poland in the mainstream
theater and that was the
point of view that i reading that i was
reading the report
mainly
so i focused on that
parts about decisions and about
why decision makers and curators are not
inviting the performances of artists
with disabilities one of reasons that i
read was about
finances
and i think i
can not agree with that because i read
that they will invite performances
if they will have extra money for that
or extra accessible budget and i think
it's all about decision
like you can choose to invite the
performance of
creators or performers performers with
disabilities
but you
maybe
have to choose to delete
another one from your program just to
choose it
maybe it's more expensive but it's
always about your decision
always we could have more money to have
a big program with all the
groups that we want to invite to our
theater or to produce something but
if we are talking that we will
be accessible if we will have extra
money
that will never stop it's just about
decisions and about
having another perspective that is there
was really happy when i found that
positive uh
content in the report about
things that
[Music]
for artists with disabilities are
bringing to the art sector that is
something really incredible and really
something passionate
that it's
something great that um
it broad
program of institutions
also i think it's really due to the
market and to the overproduction of the
institutions that i'm working in
i'm thinking about my perspective
uh that we want to
sell a lot
and
the waste production with artists with
disabilities really often needs another
time
another support and another
just
[Music]
another needs
that
really
institutions have to change their
standard weights of production and
it's not economically
good for those institutions
but it's not always be it's just we are
working in the idea sector in the
in dreams and in really beautiful things
it's not only think about it's it's not
everything about the market and the
economic stuff
um also in my head it's uh
connected with uh things that i don't
found enough in the report and i think
it's really important so the lack of
higher education for the artists with
disabilities i think it's really
important to cons to still talking about
that because the one of the arguments
and the reasons
when i'm talking with the curators
or
producers that they are not inviting
artists with disabilities is because
they don't have higher education
because
there is not
program for
learning the
artists with disabilities and you know
this is close circle just
we are still having the same
conversations i think
the one of the solutions is really
starting to
building to creating the european system
or some
erasmus project maybe something
to
create the
higher education
designed or also for not separately for
the people with disabilities but to
include them for the standard ones to
uh to work
in art
academies but also in management
academies in art with art managers
to have that topic also in art academies
really thank you phillip
i'm i'm going to next invite maria
to share your reflections on the report
thank you caroline thank you all uh for
the invitation to be here today and
share our thoughts
i'm a
white woman in her 50s short light brown
hair green eyes and i'm wearing black as
well
um the report confirms many of the
things we already know but that's really
great because many times we feel we need
to have proof of what we're saying and
now we've got it
um of course people working in the
cultural sector
expressed a lack of knowledge around
issues related to disabled artists or
disabled audiences
i have to state that that in our
particular case
in portugal we feel that we have more
and more colleagues people working in
the cultural sector who are aware of the
issues and even of some of the solutions
and the way forward
but then their directors the people who
make the decisions they don't come to
those capacity building sessions we're
promoting
so many colleagues actually say that the
first barrier is an internal barrier
when the persons
taking the decisions are not on the same
you know
they don't share
the knowledge and they don't share the
views and the priorities
um
then i would like to stress one of the
things uh philip brought up that because
these things are related the fact that
those people teaching in artistic
schools also have a lack of knowledge
around disability arts both in what
happens what's happening nationally in
portugal and internationally so disabled
people who are interested and are
getting in touch with universities
because they want to become actors or
dancers whatever musicians they get a no
for an answer and sometimes the
justification for that no is truly
unacceptable and shows lots of ignorance
a surprise for us from this report was
that disabled people are eager to then
attend performances of course there are
people eager to attend performances but
they are very few from our experience in
portugal so what we are
registering now
is a growing offer of performances which
are accessible
but the audience is not growing and why
is it not growing maybe not growing as
fast as some people would expect and we
need to be clear and realistic about
that
the arts and performances didn't were
not part of many people's lives so far
because they were not accessible so it
will take time to build this
relationship of trust
so yes we have people who are eager and
we have many more who don't even know
about
the cultural offer and the
and how accessible it is
a final point i would like to make uh
relates to the fact that the majority of
respondents expect
the ministries of culture or funding
bodies to take the lead in this
i'm i'm not going to contradict this i
just say that this is not the only way
perhaps in our case in portugal it was a
sector that got organized and created an
association it was the sector who
um reflected
intensely around these issues who
promoted capacity building
sessions who came up with ideas and
possible ways forward and then we built
a rather good relationship with the
ministry of culture and with the arts
council portugal so there's not only one
way of doing it perhaps it's us
that could start the process
so that's it for me thank you
thank you maria
okay
claudio could you please give us your
response to the report
okay thank you i'm claudio i'm
an actor a director and an educator i am
45 with the black and white airs salt
and pepper black
black shirt
and i am in a very ugly
and the naked room is an airbnb room so
there is really
nothing special
around me
i
i
agree quite a lot with the
with the report and
and what i
think it is a bit like
the dog chasing his tail because
i feel we are in the center of this
revolution we are in the
middle
and um
and so
so uh what it is
um
important are especially two things for
me first
to
uh
because i i agree completely in giving
full access
to people for school our
art school etc etc but
[Music]
this thing of course may involve also
the
other
environments for
people with
disability
because what if a person just just
doesn't want to be an artist or
something else and this is quite
it is quite important what we are doing
here now
that just
doesn't involve only art but
everything first
secondly
the
the uh
what
philip
was saying about
higher education etc
it is something
that concerns the whole
education life of a person
and
this means
that we should start considering
the fact
that a person with disability
is not
like is is lived
sometimes
sometimes in schools uh load or
something uh
strange or or whatever but it is a point
of view
that should be questioned and
investigate should be
known
and from this
point of view we can
understand what could be the
direction of that person okay in
in life in future in in dreams he names
and
everything
but also
for this
one very basic thing for me is to
also to uh
remodel the imaginary connected
to disabled people because
it should be quite clear
what i just said
that a person
is always a point of view here we are on
this earth we have
we are seven billions of different point
of view so
a person with the disability is a story
a different story to be told
so
and to be known so
it's not just
that a
a
little person or a down person or or a
person on a wheelchair is just
that
as
cinema or or
the
habilistic word
say and
but
you should really question that point of
view should really understand how a
person really is and tell
and tell
the true and
[Music]
and that for me is one of the
main focus
that that should be
considered to uh also to to
to
discuss
with the
cultural
industry
how we tell
this word
i'm next going to invite tanya
to share your reflections tanya
thank you
thank you caroline and thank you for
inviting me to share some of my
thoughts i work as a project manager at
sconestastiato in sweden malmo
i for physical description i am a woman
in my mid-40s i've got gray hair and i
am a swedish sri lankan origin i'm in my
home in front of a bookcase
um
so for me reading the report i
echo a lot of things that's already been
said but it was particularly what you
said maria it's really about confirming
many of our own experiences and our
journey in i guess becoming one of the
leading voices in sweden within dance
and disability
mainly our work as a dance company has
focused on producing commissioning and
presenting dance performances with
disabled and non-disabled dancers on our
main stage in malmo but also festivals
around sweden and abroad but another
important aspect of our work has been to
develop platforms and opportunities for
local disabled dancers to develop their
own artistic practice
um because again i echo some of the
things that both philip and maria and
sonia said that
there is a lack of access to education
and for many emerging dance disabled
dancers this platform has been the way
into being employed as dancers both
within our own
company our own dance company which is a
mainstream repertory dance company but
also
others have gone on to work with other
leading cultural organizations in sweden
uh so just to say that we are a company
of 20 dancers who work in the company we
are a small company of 45 staff
apparently and
approximately and 20 are dancers and we
really began our work towards the more
inclusive dance sector in 2011 and then
we just to give a bit of background to
the responses to the before the report
we then began to ask the questions on
why there were never any disabled
audience members coming into the theater
so very much echoing what you were
saying maria
and in finding the answer to that
question we began a dialogue with the
disabled community
and it very soon became clear that they
the disabled community were not
interested
in becoming audience members for an art
form that they felt excluded from
so very early on the driving question
instead became who gets access to the
stage and who belongs to the stage and
this question prompted us then to begin
presenting performances by inclusive
dance companies many of these were
international
to really present strong representations
of disabled dancers on stage and we also
understood that in order to instigate
change within our own organization and
providing role models for the disabled
community it was essential to employ
disabled staff
so we started to work intensively over a
initial three-year period together with
caroline brodich who's here
employing her as an autistic strategic
consultant so really working with us to
get more disabled people involved in
dance working with us to develop
strategies in how we could
become accessible for the disabled
community both as artists and as
audiences but also working with us in
making work performances with emerging
disabled dancers
a parallel to our work with caroline we
also recruited professional disabled
dancers to join the dance company
so i just wanted to give you this
background in the beginning of our
journey in order to be able to emphasize
some of the key points that the report
gives evidence to being drivers for
change so the report clearly states that
it's essential to involve disabled
people in decision making and i believe
that that's one of the key factors of
our work it's going to charter is that
it's the response from the disabled
community that informed and continues to
inform how we work
and the report also states from the
experience sector
aside that for most arts organizations
working with arts and disability in most
cases tend to focus on audiences first
artist laid there but for us as an arts
organization it was the opposite really
focusing on artists and artistic
development first and the audience later
and in our case employing disabled
dancers
within the dance company has really led
us to produce high quality dance
performances presented on our main stage
and in fact one of these performances a
duetable debt wreck
is has taught extensively both
nationally and internationally in main
stages in europe but also places outside
europe such as new york canada korea and
it's up to date actually the most toured
work that constance just ever produced
so i just also want to say that i do
believe that access for audiences is
really important equally important but i
believe that producing performances of
high artistic qualities what's going to
change the sector where disabled people
are seeing and are called to report
as active agents
rather than as passive recipient of
culture is really key
in making the work relevant for disabled
audiences in the first place
the report also clearly states that
employing disabled staff are drivers for
change and in our case it's going to
show that this is clear it is the
disabled artistic staff does the dancers
and artistic consultants that have been
the change makers within our
organization
another key factor that's mentioned in
the report which i strongly support is
how european networks and programs have
contributed to fostering knowledge and
good practice exchange
this is an experience that we share as a
cultural organization but perhaps more
significantly this is an opinion that is
voiced clearly to us from the disabled
artist community involved in the
projects
so these projects are really extremely
important for professional development
opportunities
based in schona but they also offer
unique peer-to-peer learning for men and
disabled artists that we work with
being part of a larger kind of european
disabled artist community
breaks the feeling of isolation and for
example being the only disabled dancers
within a mainstream dance company it
offers really unique opportunities to
share lived experience with other
disabled dancers that would be very hard
today in another setting
and finally there's a lot more to say
but i would like to say that i i hear
what you're saying maria and philip
about um
um not waiting around for structures and
cultural policies but i i am very
pleased that the report points strongly
towards developing um cultural policies
addressing disability and access within
the arts
because i feel that in sweden it's my
belief that in sweden we really need to
start developing specific policies
towards arts and disability with a
dedicated budget that will support
change in the cultural field
and i really feel that
we need to put much stronger emphasis
within a swedish context within the
national cultural policies we have here
on funding schemes that supports
disabled people as artists and not
merely as audiences
i mean i can say more about this but i
think the system it's of course amazing
when it's a sector driving for the
change but it also becomes a very
vulnerable and fragile
um
set up in a way because it's as an
institution the board of directors are
constantly changing the artistic
directors are changing and dedicated
staff are changing and i think that we
need to be
really
um
yeah it's too fragile we need stronger
policies to be set in place um there are
so many things that are
pinging in my head that are ways that we
could go
um with this conversation um
and i'm also very conscious of time so
i'm going to ask you all
one last question that i would like you
to think about
which is
from this massive report
what would you like
the mainstream art sector or
arts ministries or arts funders to take
from this report
one thing
that you would want
people that aren't as wise or as
experienced as any of you
to take
um
from this report
and i'm going to firstly i'm going to
ask maria just because you
uh smiling at me so that's because i'm
smiling i guess it was because of that
something's instantly popped into your
head
you know it's uh like with any issue uh
the first step is to acknowledge there
is an issue so what i would like them to
take from this report is the fact that
their lack of knowledge creates barriers
or supports barriers and they need to do
something about it
really thank you mia
sonia
just get us on that table and give us
the chance to work
with you and not
don't start and don't keep talking about
us
just start talking with us and
communicate
i think that for me that's it
thank you
claudio one thing
that you would want
other people reading this report yes
yes
it is important
that we are asked what
how we want
to be represented and what are our
needs to
fully achieve our our goals
thank you
um tanya
yeah a difficult question
i mean i
think i mean there was also in the
report a lack of actually seeing work
disable-led artistic work and i would
also really
encourage actually arts council and
funders to really go out and and see the
work that's being disabled because i
think there is a lot of preconceived
ideas about what that work might be
about
and uh and really
reiterating that for us as um
you know a personal experience as a as a
cultural organization that really
embracing diversity is what develops the
art form and in in a very selfish way
will allow us to survive as an art form
to be still relevant and and um have
something to say about today's society
so that's
i guess also it's about gaining
knowledge about
change for funders and arts councils
that's the one thing
thank you tanya
and philip
one thing
okay maybe to system up all the report
it's just uh
stop making excuses
everything is clear
sources are given
you have all the knowledge to change the
system and
we are just knocking the door to to
constantly from yes to yes it's time
really time for that it's hard to find
one you know
uh
key point uh key findings from the
report to just
give us a
the most important it's just uh there is
a lot of excuses here but also a lot of
solutions
that we don't have a knowledge but we'd
have a knowledge from artists with
disabilities so you have it or not it's
just
maybe decide if you want to do it or not
because it's not about your
wanting it's about our need and about
our need and our right so just stop
making
excuses maybe this
perfect
thank you to all of the panelists um
that have shared their insights uh with
me
in this session
um
yeah it's been a joy to be sharing space
with you so thank you all for your
time
um
and your wisdom
that you've shared
oh caroline i am so jealous of your
conversation uh thank you to you and to
all of those panelists
um
but i know that i also had a
conversation this week that you were
jealous of and that is
a conversation
earlier this week with barbara gesler
the head of unit creative europe program
of the european union
so
perhaps we can see that conversation now
barbara thank you so much for
joining us i really appreciate your time
um before we start i wonder if i could
ask you to give a one sentence visual
description of yourself please
yes sure good morning i'm barbara gesler
i'm a blonde
middle-aged woman and i put on some very
red lipstick this morning
thank you
um
we're going to jump straight to
the questions
the report shows that european networks
and transnational collaborations have
incredibly
have been incredibly important to the
development and sharing of knowledge of
disabled artists of accessible cultural
practices amongst arts managers
and i think the the figures in the
report show that uh european and
international
performing arts networks and are
mentioned by 32 percent of the
respondents as their trusted uh sources
uh when looking at for information about
disabled artists and this compares
uh with a much lower level for national
performing arts network so the
the strength of the european and
international field is is clearly um
evident
so my first question is in your capacity
as the head of creative europe program
at the european union how do you reflect
on the report
i find the report extremely rich and
extremely inspiring and extremely
revealing as well it also shows the
weaknesses that we are seeing currently
but also
very
uh you know very encouraging that
there's such a wish also and an
awareness
uh that you the european level can
actually do
and support
uh the development of the participation
of disabled artists in the cultural and
creative process at the european level
that i find that extremely
stimulating and encouraging
and i think that will
form the basis and can form the basis
for us to be
even more proactive and even
you know encouraging good
uh good practices more
and so you think there might be a role
for european institutions to support and
encourage this well you know that the
european union has launched a disability
strategy
uh not so long ago
and therefore all services of the
commission are actually called
uh to take into account
uh special needs that people may have
not only when it comes to funding or
culture but also obviously other
policies so this is a this is a
cross-cutting issue for the entire
commission therefore also for us for our
programs and all the funding programs
that exist so naturally we are asked to
take this into consideration
now that's only the financial part that
the report also reflects upon but i
would go actually further i would say
that there's also of course in our
political cooperation with member stage
the national level that is also of
course highly
reflected in the report there's a role
for european institutions to play also
when it comes to raising awareness
and our projects that's the other part
of your question or of your introduction
ben
is that we believe that via the networks
and the partnerships that are being
created a lot of awareness can be
can be raised
and
we need to probably do more also when it
comes to
highlighting and showcasing those
projects to a general audience or also
to decision makers at local regional or
national level
and the report has def
definitely as usual with your work i
must say
inspired me to think how we could do
that maybe also in a very
condensed and targeted format we could
we could look into our instruments and
say who could we ask maybe to organize
events where we look specifically at
this topic
and where we invite
decision makers
at other levels etc so
it has definitely
the report has definitely
laid the basis in me
to
to look at what we could do better
that's
really great to hear i have to say i
think one of the things that comes from
through very strongly from the report is
the national asymmetries that some
countries are much further in the
journey
uh than than others
and specifically one of the challenges
is that um
[Music]
the report says that european arts
managers want to see national
institutions such as ministries of
culture and national arts funders as the
ideal sources of information
to share best practice
but
the report and statistics also show that
currently they're not playing that role
and also that those organizations the
arts funders
report themselves of a very
um a very strong lack of knowledge in
this area so we have this dichotomy and
i mean you've perhaps already explained
but this
uh i suppose many of us are wondering
how we
escape this dichotomy how do
we
support cultural ministries arts funders
to increase their knowledge and and it
sounds as though
the european institutions can play a
role in that
well
yes and no of course you know in the
area of culture uh
maybe not everybody knows we're working
in an environment
where what you are saying is
is the is the rule basically meaning
um culture and creativity are mostly
dealt with at other levels than the
european level
because we're in an area of so-called
subsidiarity
so there's not an obligatory
role in that sense that the european
institutions can necessarily play in the
area of culture but what we do
is
promote the exchange of information
promote the exchange of experience
make sure that for example via our
program creative europe that
networks and partnerships are created
that can then
help each other also so it's more of a
bottom-up approach
but i agree that there
could be more that could be done also to
invite the other levels to share better
and more targeted information
and
i think we have to we have to probably
jointly reflect how
how this can be done the european level
with its disability strategy has has
already
asked upon member states to be active to
fight
discrimination on the basis of
disabilities and rather also in the
positive sense to to
stimulate the participation in all areas
of always walks of life for people with
disabilities so there's already an
approach there and i'm pretty sure that
we can kind of
link in we are involved in this process
but link in further in the
implementation of this strategy
i would like to say ben that already in
the new creative europe program
maybe not everybody is aware but we have
included
co-legislators have included
a paragraph an article and that rules
for the whole program for for all of our
funding
uh and the article says that the program
objectives shall be pursued in a way
that
encourages inclusion
in particular and one of the main
articles there says ensure that people
with disabilities
and others of course have access to the
cultural and creative sectors and that
encourage their active participation in
those sectors both in the creative
process and in audience development
and i can't say
i think i don't flatter you too much but
it's also thanks to the work that you
have been doing
that this awareness
was there that we needed to
really
really have a concrete article
that would uh that would require all
projects to also adhere
to this stipulation in the in the
program
it was i have to say it was great to see
uh to see that uh as uh especially that
disabled artists and arts professionals
were mentioned i think we've exchanged
before about many assumptions in the
cultural field that when we talk about
uh disabled people's
access to culture we talk about
audiences but actually
what felt incredibly um
exciting about reading that was the
disabled artists and arts professionals
were listed there
and our we look on with anticipation and
excitement to see
how that
how that
makes itself manifest the report clearly
shows that
um
some of the dedicated arts and
disability projects supported by
creative europe and
europe beyond access
we are one of them but many others are
mentioned such as
unlabelled impart
tanya laline and i i can't remember
all of them
but they're mentioned in the report as
as good practice
and of course one of the things we
uh are very interested to see is whether
um
major projects which are not
specifically
aimed at deaf and disabled artists are
able and encouraged to
um
to welcome disabled people when they
apply and and they meet the the criteria
of application for those programs
so
we look forward to well i hope that
some of those changes you've made
help uh cultural managers take that
extra moment of reflection before they
launch into their programs
[Music]
yet to see of course the results you
know we have just officially launched a
program where currently in the
evaluation of the first corporation
projects it's i was happy to see that
among you know this is the biggest bulk
of our of our support at the moment uh
that uh 17 of the proposals ticked the
priority of social inclusion
and there will be projects that will
definitely deal with this and we are
also briefing of course our experts to
look at this
so
but i want to say is that we maybe need
to also
see how it turns out in the first year
and then maybe also see what can be
changed adapted or
or tightened strengthened in the in the
in the following calls
uh if there's things that we can do to
learn from the first experiences if this
is already taken enough on board or not
it's at the moment we're still in our
first experience of the new program
yeah it'll be really interesting to see
and i know that the european arts and
disability cluster have made some
suggestions about ways that
the application process or the budget
process could be improved to encourage
um
all organizations to consider access
costs but we realized that this first
step was an
important one especially for the as it
covers the rules for the eight year for
the eight-year program so a key moment
really
may i ask you a couple of questions
about creative europe specifically then
and i
the report talks about the knowledge of
arts managers including the knowledge of
policymakers and funders and i wonder
how you would characterize the knowledge
levels within your own program and team
and do you think there are concrete
steps that creative europe can take to
improve your own knowledge levels here
well i think the negotiations have
already uh
largely
increased awareness
of the program you know we've been
discussing also
of course the commission makes a
proposal
then you know the european parliament
and the member states
legislate on this proposal and during
this negotiation we had lots of
exchange also on those topics i must i
must say and can reveal to you
that this has been a topic and rightly
so
so already through this process over the
past two two years i think something
has happened in my team obviously we've
been
uh we've been very much involved my team
has uh has backed me very much of course
in in those negotiations so there is
awareness we are asked as i said before
also by the other services and the
responsible services to contribute to
what is called inter-service
consultation when it comes to pieces of
legislation or programs etc so also
in the other colleagues are also more
aware of this topic and this is where i
think also the top-down
necessity exists you know we cannot just
rely on projects coming up from the
bottom saying this is
this is what we want to do we also need
to
to encourage this
and we now have a concrete opportunity
to do so via the program
uh and i will i will take away also from
the report that probably more needs to
be done also at our level and
and will reflect on how concretely
we could do that because you're
absolutely right it's also
it's also an awareness in the
institutions that that that needs to
exist uh
not only and there i'm also very clear
and i'm happy about the article that we
have in the program not only about the
challenges but also about the
opportunities
and
i would like to
i would like to bring also this message
a bit further that we're not talking
about a problematic area but an area
which is enriching
and uh
and beautiful so
um
that's that's what i would like to work
on also in the in the future years based
on the report
well thank you in particular for that
that comment around the top down i i
think it's a theme of of today's webinar
actually that uh this knowledge and and
drive towards greater accessibility is
only really
successful when it comes from senior
decision makers rather than delegated to
to a single member of the team uh lower
down the orcanogram
and uh and i think
clearly
um
you've reflected that by being here
yourself today
um
what a horrible experience to watch
oneself on screen for 20 minutes
but i hope you found it as interesting
and
encouraging as i did that
barbara gesler there from the creative
europe programme was making commitments
to develop and work more
and i've got some news which is
news since
i had that conversation with barbara
that today barbara's team at the
creative europe
unit
have
formally presented the time to act
report to the european council's
cultural affairs committee so that's a
the committee that prepares the work of
eu ministers for culture
in a wide range of areas related to eu
cultural cooperation so that feels like
another small but exciting step
we're about to
um
start the question and answer session um
which caroline will lead and
[Music]
just to let you know that during that
session uh on your screen will appear
four
survey questions um these are helpful
for us to evaluate our work and also to
evaluate the diversity of our audience
and it also includes information we need
to report to our funder so please we'd
be grateful if you would consider
responding and of course your responses
are anonymous but i'll hand over to
carolina
thanks ben
um and thanks for that amazing
conversation it's it's heartening and
exciting to
uh
kind of see how that rolls out and what
happens next
so now it's time for your questions and
we have received lots of questions what
i would like to say is that i'm going to
focus on questions particularly related
to the research
um
because we're going to be talking to the
researchers of that have prepared the
report so the team from um on the move
so i'd like to welcome back
um geordi
johann from on the move and i'd also
like to welcome um marie lessor who is
the director of on the move and
has overseen the research
so welcome back uh to the three of you
i'm just waiting for people to turn
their cameras on
and come back
hi johann
hi
hi
um
so we have received
several questions well many questions
from people um
and i am just going to start
[Music]
with
actually i'm going to ask marie if you
can first begin by just giving us a
visual description of yourself marie
yes hello
good morning so i am a white woman in my
mid-40s and i have middle long brown
hair and i am wearing a black top and i
have a messy shelf behind me i am
working from home thank you
really thank you and thanks for being
here to be part of this conversation
and having presented with such a
fantastic
and rich report
um
i'm going to start with a question that
we didn't quite get to answer before
from julienne
which
i wonder if you could speak about any
elements or parts of the research
which you decided not to include
in the report and
why did they not make the cut
or at least the parts it took much more
discussion than others how did you
decide what went in and what didn't
here's the short answer question
mari do you want to start or should i go
um i will just maybe say one thing and
after i give you the the word just to
say that uh when you will see the the
full report uh we um
commonly also uh decided with the
british council so with ben in
particular to
not to put
the name of
specific people that were interviewed
because
some people really
wanted to remain anonymous because you
know in the kind of critical feedback
they could have on some question for
instance so we did respect that so that
way there is not the least
very precise list of the people that
were interviewed but they were very key
of course between the last process of
the research
iran
yes in terms of
our farm topics that were not um
discussed much
but would need to you know to to
i mean would need to to to be
investigated further of course as we've
seen the access to arts education i mean
in the panel in this in the study uh it
came very very
often in conversation and access to
vocational
uh but also informal education is
something that was not part of our
mandate to investigate in a way but
would deserve really to have a like a
piece of research and probably a lot of
conversation with with art education
stakeholders
a second um topic that was not uh
investigated and could be very
interesting in the future is
the media coverage or the visibility of
disabled artists
not only in the mainstream press but
also in all the specialized press the
press all the media that
are very useful for gatekeepers
artistic leaders to investigate
what's out there to gather collect
information to scout for talents and
artistic projects and this media
coverage of visibility issue
as we have heard also is pretty high in
the agenda
maybe something that is more niche but
somehow is also very interesting in
terms of
reaching out to
disabled audiences and making the work
available for them and accessible for
them is the perception by non-disabled
artists themselves
and why
they choose or choose to not make their
work accessible and this is a a topic
that is you know a bit tricky to
investigate probably
but in terms of raising the awareness i
mean there is a point uh to make and of
course in this research we didn't look
at
you know artistic processes artistic
quality and i know it is always a
question that pops up you know in all
the conversation what is exactly a high
artistic quality
but i guess this is something that
would need a way more focus on the
aesthetics and the artistic research
processes etc which was not really the
focus of this particular research i
don't know if you you want to add
something georgie or mary
uh johan thank you for addressing the
the question of quality because that was
a question that had come up about
how do we it often is something that
um there is an assumption made about the
work of deaf and disabled artists and
its quality um i think a lot so it's
it's interesting that it came up
um we've got a question from hannah
quigley uh which uh is about
given the timing of the report happening
in the last two years
um
hannah's aware that there's a lot of
organizations where staff were on
furlough or on reduced hours or there
were lots of changes in staffing
structures
um
connected to sonya's point in the panel
that i chaired
uh hannah's wondering if the report has
enough accurate and detailed data that
will make it useful and meaningful
country by country
um
at this in in what's already there
does that make sense is there enough
details
and accurate information
um yeah i can i can answer this one if
you if you want
um i mean
the report has been conducted between
2020 and 2021 but it also builds on
quite a lot of uh literature on this
field that exists before
and it has examined
also the trends in the evolution that
have been visible in some countries
including very positive progress being
done in some countries which shows how
when there is a mobilization by the
sector when there are policies when
there are specific measures adopted
progress can be made
and then it has also of course examined
the reality at this particular point in
time which also serves to highlight
how covet has brought about a new set of
challenges that will need to be
addressed which add up to those that
were already existing
um i think at the same time as regards
the
representativeness of the of the
findings uh i mean firstly it's
important to note that
we did
a survey that has a number of
answers per each country but then that
is complemented with a number of
interviews with a number of
conversations some of them with
individuals others with networks
there's been a number of uh
presentations at national and european
white uh events and then we've
complement that with the literature so
uh i think there's quite a wealth uh and
a diverse set of sources that have been
used but i think what's more important
someone was saying
uh in and
in the conference in the previous
conversations is for this topic to be
put onto the table
uh and then
for let's say for this somehow to raise
awareness that no matter what the
departing point is
this is an issue to be addressed at the
society level and that public
authorities and other actors need to
address this reality and the best way to
address that is to consult with local
stakeholders including people with
disabilities in their particular country
and of course then the the the
situations the challenges the needs will
be very different and of course
we cannot provide recommendations that
will be valid at each
specific context but there's uh a number
of general recommendations that really
should guide
change
across and and of course then adapt that
to to each particular situation so this
would be more or less my my answer to
that and yeah i'm not sure if someone
else wants to add this
great thanks jordy
um
we have a question i mean there's lots
of people kind of asking questions about
uh
kind of moments that you found or
examples that you found and some of them
will obviously be in the report but
you've had to in making the
recommendations had to not pinpoint one
specific thing but but overall but for
you as researchers um
there's a question that's come from
aiden howard about
given the systemic barriers that prevent
equal participation in
in the workforce and this is a long-term
challenge
did you find
any kind of outstanding examples in your
research
that
others could follow are there models or
paradigms
um that
other people could employ to
to try in their organization that really
stood out to you
as you're researching
i'm not sure i i fully understand um if
we are talking about um
supporting um
or engaging with disabled audiences and
also sometimes with
engage uh engaging with a disabled
artist
we can see that as some a specialized
organization like assassin kultura
in portugal and the wonderful maria but
a similar organization or services made
available in some cities and i'm
thinking you know in geneva or in in
france you have specialized organization
agencies that support
accessible
accessibility in the arts and they
high-level expertise their commitment
really makes a difference on the ground
i mean you can see in these particular
contexts that
they have an immense added value to
support um
a change of structural change but also
to provide a lot of guidance to
stakeholders and to communication
marketing teams to artistic leaders to
local governments so they are recognized
highly recognized and highly appreciated
so
one element i mean one striking element
was you could really see the difference
uh among you know countries where you
have this specialized organization and
when you don't
um so maybe this is one answer
and of course after that
you have a different level of
commitments and
many
avenues and festivals across europe are
working towards engaging with disabled
audiences so they have
a know-how
and they invest a lot in pr
communication relationship managers with
different you know groups they want to
target and engage with
it's less strong for engaging with
artists
but
you can see that the again the more
the more
they have staff with the lived
experience or with disabilities
there is a strong
commitment
of the entire organization to take on
board and to really
adapt practices and take measures so
again
the involvement of
people with disabilities and workers
with disabilities
is is very key in this development and
you can be on the same territory in the
same country and have
like two two a very very good example
and a very very bad example but this uh
the personnel really makes a difference
yeah i suppose uh yeah to complement
that i mean i suppose there is also a
sense that in in some countries
like the uk for instance and in
particular periods there's been
a kind of an
ecosystem of uh public support
involvement and engagement from
specialized organizations
and and of course
resources that have contributed to
change
and and let's say it's probably that
combination of different levels and
different actors working together and
reinforcing one another that
that is very important one of the
results of that is also
the availability in some countries more
than in others of
an important number of toolkits guides
and practical resources
as well as people that have the
expertise to share
and and
because despite the differences across
countries there's some
[Music]
there's some solutions and there's some
solutions that are quite universal and
that could be shared there is
potentially
a potential
for that expertise and those guides and
those toolkits to be translated to be
made available and somehow let's say for
that knowledge that often exists in
pockets to be uh
more disseminated more broadly and and
only that step
could have a potential to to generate a
very substantial change
thanks jordy
um murray i want to come to you with my
last question
which uh links really nicely to what
your hand was saying
about um so on the move has obviously
been deeply involved in this research
for some time
um
on behalf of british council and europe
beyond access
do you think in
doing this research um
your organization has changed do you
think you've gained more knowledge
because of this work and that that will
have
i don't know what will that be what will
the impact of that be going forward if
it has
yeah thank you very much caroline for
the for this question um i think if the
organization has changed is maybe not to
me particularly to say that but more
also actually to people who follow us
but we
our website so just in a nutshell on the
movies the mobility information networks
our main mission is to provide
information about mobility opportunities
um for artists and cultural
professionals what i can really share up
to now that first of all indeed the
process
of this research has been longer than
expected with also
because of of the pandemic but at the
same time it has brought also
in the process
um you know all the moment of
interaction and also like to get
feedback also like to feed uh very much
this research and if so
jordy anyone mentioned in particular we
had like different events together with
the british council for instance in
different country and so much of the
conversation happened i would say during
this event but also behind the scene
and um
so it's and we can see also in this very
meeting that it's as if we have two
conversations here this conversation
here and we see also a network in the
making in the chat with people wanting
to
that would like also very much to stay
in touch what i can say at the level of
the
of the
of on the movies that we have gained i
mean in a very humble way i would say
but we have gained a more um
information a more resource to make some
decision for instance in the way we make
uh information more accessible through
our
report for instance we work with a
designer who is now working with a font
which is also a usual font which is more
for instance accessible for in relation
with visual impairment also with some
new feature as well on our website so
all this question of accessibility and
we in terms of
content of the information as well we
are we try um and it's a long term
process of course to identify more
opportunities for artists and cultural
professionals in situation of disability
and all to identify sometime into
mainstream type of calls and
opportunities those criteria that can
also comply very much
with them
and
a last point i would like also very much
to
to to say and create even more long-term
process
networks like ourselves are also like
very much into advocacy so the fact of
doing this research helped us as well to
fine-tune
our
advocacy i would say argumentation in
favor of mobility
of artists and cultural professionals
which also embed more the particular
situation of artists and cultural
professionals with disability so of
course it's part of the process and i
think it's tanya erhart who say in one
of the first presentation of the timing
to act because we had the initial
finding first and she's saying it's not
a matter of ticking the box but it's
really a matter of process and i think
we are there and and thanks uh also for
this collaboration with the british
council and the eba european access
project
thank you so much to the on the move
team to geordi to johann and to
melbourne
and yes i'd like to echo your thanks
caroline to that the whole team for this
remarkable piece of work
um also to thank everyone who's taken
part in today we're just about to do one
last thing in the last minutes of this
this webinar but um and that is to watch
the video
uh made by claudia getani who you met
earlier but um i should note that in the
chat as you uh as mary mentioned
one of our
attendees uh
has posted a google document in the very
clever
uh foresight that we as british councils
cannot share your details with each
other um we have haven't got the right
to share but
a google drive has a google document has
been created if you would like
to post your information there for you
yourselves to share with each other and
keep in touch it's one of the sad things
about not working face to face although
there are huge
we're advantages to the end we're going
to take
five more minutes of your time and i
hope you will bear with us for three
minutes over the allotted time i think
you'll want to
in the earlier panel discussion we heard
from claudia gettani from the
independent association
of disabled artists in italy called
aldiqua
claudio has just directed a film made by
aldiqua and we thought this would be the
perfect moment at which to share it
this is where if you would like to
listen to an english sound recording of
um
what's happening we encourage you to go
to the interpretation button and click
on english there will be nothing there
in the italian section so just click on
english but otherwise you can uh
listen to it in italian with english
subtitles on screen and as usual in the
cc
closed caption box
um
we will be ending with that film so i
would just like to say thank you to all
of you from across the world
for attending and we hope to remain in
touch with you and uh and we will inform
you more about this report and the work
of europe beyond access
so with uh without any more delay we
were going to kind of hand over to this
m
[Music]
[Music]
neurological
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
monkey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you